what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into all-new
all-different guardians of the galaxy
this is kind of a weird a weird little
situation here and the reason why is
because on the whole when it came to
all-new all-different marvel most riders
simply just sort of picked up where they
left off before all you know before
secret Wars started you know for example
when it came to like the spider-man
landscape you know you had superior
spider-man than you had a couple
spider-man stories then you went into
Secret Wars and then we came out and it
just basically picked up where
spider-man left off before Secret Wars
ever happened and so in a lot of ways
Marvel does kind of treated Secret Wars
as if it never took place which is kind
of disappointing because the story was
quite literally written to give Marvel a
clean slate and to basically reboot
everything so it has kind of seemed like
a squandered opportunity but the fact
remains here that Brian Michael Bendis
did not go that route and one of the
funny things here is that Bendis is
actually going to retcon his own story
which is really kind of weird but the
fact remains here that during the events
of Secret Wars we got what is called the
guardians of nowhere now the guardians
of nowhere is not widely important and
in fact we can leave it out in its
entirety but there are a couple things
that we need a reference but in truth I
don't really see a reason to go back and
cover guardians of nowhere I mean it's
just part of the secret war story it was
just kind of there and there's maybe one
or two things that matter but what we
end up finding out here is that Ben
Grimm is effectively part of the
guardians of the galaxy now again Brian
Michael Bendis is basically going to
focus on this once we get towards the
end of this story basically bringing Ben
Grimm in but for those of you guys who
are kind of kind of curious about what's
been going on with the Fantastic Four
and I get this question a lot you know
where's Reed Richards where's valaria
Richards where Susan storm Franklin
Richards that kind of thing during
Hickman's run and Secret Wars basically
the story ended with Franklin Richards
valaria Reed and Susan alongside the
molecule man creating new universes and
that's where like the clean slate came
in because it was basically them making
universes and then just chucking them
out into the void that would eventually
become the multiverse and so because of
that it was effectively a clean slate
now in terms of all-new all-different
marvel Ben Grimm was brought back and so
was Johnny Storm but Johnny Storm
basically was allied with the Inhumans
because aside from being part of the
Fantastic Four there's really nothing
you can do with his character I mean I
wouldn't read a story about Johnny Storm
by himself he's just not that
interesting to me Ben Grimm is much the
same way and so what Marvel did is they
basically paired them off with different
things now I would surmise for the comic
Brian Michael Bendis hatch and marvel he
most likely just said I want Ben Grimm
and I want to put him on guardians of
the galaxy and that was really the end
of the discussion but what bindus does
here when it comes to Kitty Pryde
leading the guardians of the galaxy is
it kind of comes out of the guardians of
nowhere but at the same time it doesn't
innocence the guardians of nowhere was
just kind of the characters who were
there didn't know each other the way
that we traditionally think of them but
they still function in some capacity as
a group in truth again we can basically
disregard guardians of nowhere and we
can basically just say that at the end
of our last story when Peter quill
became emperor of spartax he had to
vacate his role as a guardian of the
galaxy and Kitty Pryde his fiancee at
the time basically took its place and
that's all we really need to know I mean
we still have like agent venom we've
still got Groot we still got rocket we
still have Drax we have the traditional
people that we know now one of the more
controversial aspects of this story is
that Kitty Pryde basically became
star-lord now for a lot of Peter quill
curacao I don't know how many are
actually out there but for a lot of
Peter quill Peter quill furious you know
looking at forum posts and so on and so
forth in their mind Peter quill was the
only star-lord and so to see somebody
take up the mantle was kind of something
that they were like is this really
what's going to be going on now like now
we have a we have somebody else who
store we have somebody else who's
Captain America like these are
identities up along to the characters
you know they're not simply namesakes
but in truth they are
I mean Captain America is a name he'll
by whoever it is that picks up the
shield Bucky Barnes has done it in L Sam
Wilson has done it when it came to Thor
it's any number of people who can just
pick up Thor's hammer and maybe come
forward as controversial as that may be
if Marvel says is true then that means
it's true because they're literally the
ones they came a story so again that's
one of the things that kind of causes a
lot of a division among kind of a fans
is how they view comics versus how
comics are presented by Marvel so you
know it creates all kinds of different
splits and dichotomies and so on and so
forth but the fact remains here the
Kitty Pryde operating as a really know
really as the the leader so to speak of
the guardians of the galaxy actually
brings her in direct conflict with
rocket row two now in truth they're
basically just kind of going against the
Chitauri army the reason why is because
the basically is kind of snatching up an
object from the Tatari under the guise
that each Atari themselves if they have
it they're inherently going to do
something nefarious with it I mean it's
really just kind of a plot device
designed to bring Kitty Pryde and Peter
quill back together again but the fact
remains here that with her coming into
conflict with rocket raccoon rocket
himself is in fact a leader of the team
he's the one who basically kind of
reform
and it's usually always been that way
like whenever it was at Peter quill was
not part of the Guardians rocket was the
guy who was running the show with with
Kitty Pryde being here under the mantle
of star-lord she's kind of stepping into
the role that was the more or less the
leader of the team but she really isn't
it's kind of one of those weird
situations it's really more of like
perception and reality but the fact
remains here that you know we kind of
jump back to spar texts and what we end
up finding out here is that Peter cools
life sucks like it is a terrible life
for him to leave as the Emperor of our
attacks because it's nothing but
meetings all day about like defense
strategies and like economics and how
much money is being spent where it's
like the least exciting thing as an
emperor you would expect you were like a
neighbor of a planet you would think of
yourself as something akin to a warlord
but you're just leading these massive
battles and huge conflicts and so on but
this is all politics and that's really
just kind of the world is play now in
truth we're actually going to find out
are the people who were basically
running the show the council or actually
working against Peter quill to
effectively just kind of send him
running it's going to be one of these
weird weird scenarios but the funny
little tidbits here that's what I like
about what it is that bindus does is he
injects these funny little things the
question that's asked by Ben Grimm is
there's a lot of things that are out
there that I know about that just
haven't been answered for example the
Infinity Gauntlet like no one knows
where it is
no one knows where the Infinity stones
are like what if the Chitauri had them
and what if the Infinity Gauntlet is
inside this maybe it's not the Infinity
Gauntlet maybe it's something deadly
maybe is like the ultimate nullifier or
something like that but it's kind of
funny because what dennis is doing is
kind of building on the idea of Ben
Graham remember as part of the Fantastic
Four they've seen and done it all
everything from fighting Galactus to
meeting the one above all they've done
everything and so when Ben Grimm is out
in space he's kind of back home again it
was kind of where he feels like he
belongs but he's also like look guys
there's some deadly stuff out there and
it may be inside this container and the
guardians are just kind of like well I
mean we kind of have to see what's in it
we'd like to know what's inside and so
again what they end up doing is
traveling back to spartax now again
their arrival here actually comes with
the arrival of Gamora now this basically
feeds into more or less the idea of
Gamora losing her powers of the
blackboard X that's really one of the
things that Ben doesn't focus on the
blackboard X was really more of like a
filler story arc you know the all-new
x-men didn't really even care about the
aftermath
none of that was really rolled over
aside from like you know arcane
I guess angel you know having these
fiery wings as the result of his black
vortex powers but on the whole the
all-new x-men line of stories just kind
of treated it like it didn't exist and
even the guardians of the galaxy did so
to a degree but only insofar they would
reference it from time to time and then
Gamora had her powers but that was
really it I mean there wasn't like this
great big huge aftermath you know in
guardians of the galaxy for the black
vortex story it was there and then it
was done but the idea here is that
gomorrah's basically been fighting a
person by the name of hala and the goal
here is to basically remove her powers
knows exactly what happened she
basically says look I sacrificed the
last of my blackboard X powers just to
get here and escaped with my life
and this is kind of cool because what
Bendis was doing is basically giving us
this flow here who is almost nine
omnipotent now the important thing to
keep in mind is that hala herself is not
indestructible
and she basically has your standard
breed physiology so super strength
durability that kind of thing the same
kind of abilities like Marvel Allah Kree
the issue with this is that she served
as part of the accuser Corps but the
difference is that she does not have a
universal weapon now if those guys who
don't know within the Creed landscape
you have what are called the accuser
Corps and they're basically judge jury
and executioner they will show up to a
place and you although operate basically
as the police force of you know the
galaxy even the universe to some degrees
and you'll basically say you are accused
and you've been found guilty and you
will stand for your crimes usually that
means you're going to die but they have
a universal weapon which is something
akin to Thor's hammer but a lot more
capable in terms of what it can do so we
can create force fields energy
projections different things like that
Thor's hammer can do some of that stuff
so we don't really see it very often
like we don't really see Thor using his
hammer to summon you know summon
thunderstorms we usually see it to
summon lightning but that's really the
extent of it but Thor's hammer has
actually had a lot of different
capabilities over the years but the fact
remains here with regards to holla
she basically shares the namesake of the
Kree homeworld but she basically carries
a staff that has energy projection
capabilities or something along those
lines business doesn't really go into a
whole lot of detail he just really kind
of shows it what it shows us what he can
do by circumstance as opposed to giving
us the alarm I'm fine line description
of his capabilities and that's pretty
standard when it comes to Brian Michael
Bendis writing but the fact you names
during the black vortex line of storage
or during that event Jason of Spartak
operating under the guise of mr. Knights
you know the father of Peter flow had
basically obliterated the home planet of
the Kree now of course again this has
basically been dissuading things down
meeting into into Secret Wars but when
Halle had returned back from a mission
she had found virtually everything that
she knew destroyed and swore a blood
debt you know against the guardians of
the galaxy and that's really all we need
to know about her origin story about her
backstory we don't really need a whole
ton of information and that's kind of a
good thing about the way that Bendis
writes it he'll basically just kind of
be like hey this character did this and
now they want to fight the Guardians and
that's all we need we don't need this
great big huge grandiose complex
explanation not by any standard of
measure and it's interesting and it's
there if we choose to delve into it but
it's not really a requirement but the
fact remains Pollan showing up here it
shows us a couple of things one with her
creepy physiology coming into play she's
able to withstand you know punches from
Ben Grimm now this is kind of an
interesting quagmire because I would
surmise that in this story Bendis is
actually kind of powering down vin grimm
because Ben Grimm is wildly strong and
he's able to go toe-to-toe with the
Incredible Hulk now that's up to a point
The Incredible Hulk will just get so
angry that he'll just while you're just
just overpowered Ben Grimm in the
extreme and Grimm won't stand a chance
but you know in his normal basic I'm
just cutting I'm a little mist
Incredible Hulk form he will be able to
go toe-to-toe with Ben Grimm this was a
man exchanged blows on a multitude of
occasions yo Ben Grimm has been able to
go toe-to-toe with Thor so showing him
going toe-to-toe with Halle gives us one
of two possibilities either Halle is
wildly powerful in terms of her strength
and durability more so than we would
expect from any normal creep or - Ben
Grimm is not as powerful as he used to
be now could just be that you know
business is just going by way of the
story as it's written and just kind of
calling it a day and showing us what Ben
can do but the fact remains with hollow
recovering from the attack Drax actually
takes her staff notice was kind of
interesting because this gives us a
different perspective of her staff and
it's a bit not everybody can pick it up
so it's kind of like this Thor's hammer
scenario the difference is that if a
person were to successfully be able to
pick up Thor's hammer the hammer is not
going to issue like an energy backlash
against it right like it's not going to
you know soon like a feedback and
basically kill them or incapacitate them
they'll just be able to wield it and
throw it at people with the traditional
view on how we look at Thor's hammer
versus how we look at the stop this
staff has an energy feedback so if a
person tries to pick it up that
shouldn't be able to lift it the staff
itself will basically shocked it now of
course with Drax being as durable as he
is and being as powerful as he is he's
not going to be killed but if it were a
normal person like you know Kitty Pryde
or a person like Starr
or to Rocket Raccoon you know if they
were to pick it up they would be
completely and totally incinerated now
of course this leads into a direct
conflict between holla and the guardians
and then she into passin Tate's every
last one of them including Drac so again
the implication that Venice is giving us
here is that harlot is really just that
strong she's really just that capable of
a fighter now of course because of the
fact that her motivation is all rooted
in violence and wanting to see
everything that Peter quill loves come
crashing down she in turn basically
intends to you know destroy the planet
spark-tastic self now at this point we
actually jump over to a guy by the name
of yota now yo Tech was a guy who showed
up in guardians of nowhere and as far as
I can tell he was designed to be a
one-off he was just supposed to be a
one-off character just for the sake of
being able to give us stories about
guardians of nowhere but then this
actually chose to roll him back in now
the cool thing as a business is going to
give us basically a brief overview of
what his characters about here in a
little bit but for the moment he's
basically tracking down the guardians of
the galaxy now again to come and kinda
go ahead and just jump into this brief
little synopsis real quick yo tat was
basically a guy in guardians of nowhere
who was involved in almost every
conceivable form of a form of crime
whether it was trafficking gambling
gun-running whatever the case may be he
was involved in it all he would
basically take his cut of everything but
in truth he was more of a thug than
anything else the problem with this as
he eventually came into contact with the
guardians of nowhere the Guardian court
and the Nova Corps themselves now of
course the conflict between all these
different guys was effectively stymied
when Angela of the four cores showed out
during Secret Wars and it's kind of
brought his reign to an end really fast
but for the most part he's just taking
this to mean that the guardians were
meddling in his affairs so it's not some
complex spaces behind why he's trying to
get revenge on them it's basically just
him irritated a medal in his affairs and
he wants revenge it's pretty basic I
mean it's really more akin to what you
would expect from like the kingpin you
know or Diamond Head you know some
villain back on earth that's going
against like daredevil or spider-man or
somebody like that it's very human and
very date so this has really been just
telling us there's not much meat and
potatoes behind the character of you
Todd he's a pretty basic guy like he's
not really complicated by any standard
of measurement now of course he's also
broader at least also visited by the
queen brood now the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that in
our previous videos on guardians of the
galaxy we had talked about how the
Galactic Council as it had been led by
JSON of spartax had basically turned
against him but with JSON of spartax
being ousted from the planet Spartak as
Emperor the various members of the
Galactic Council saw this as an
opportunity to basically remove Spartak
from the equation and take them out of
being the world of protectors of the
galaxy or leaders of the galaxy
effectively creating a power vacuum that
when in turn allow them to takes part
taxes place now the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that what
the Queen brood did you know with the
supreme intelligence basically being
destroyed all the other members of the
Galactic Council being obliterated the
Queen brood actually traveled to the
negative zone and met with a nihilist so
this is really kind of cool because this
is one of the first indications that we
get of Annihilus existing in all-new
all-different marvel we knew it was only
a matter of time I mean you can't do a
story like annihilation from 2006 where
Annihilus engage the main Marvel
Universe with the intention of just
wiping out all life kidnaps Galactus
uses them as a power source all that
kind of stuff you can't have a story
like that and then just never use
Annihilus again he's too intrinsic to
the Marvel cosmology and at this point
just too popular of a character let go
and so because of that we basically have
this scenario taking place with a crude
queen intends to basically use the
forces of Annihilus and a negative zone
to launch a campaign against the main
Marvel Universe now whether or not this
will lead into something similar to
annihilation I don't know and I highly
doubt it to be honest annihilation was
such a massive event in and of itself
and the story was a necessity when it
was first written I have a hard time
believing we would see something just
like that because what you're talking
about
is a force numbering in the billions
just invading the main Marvel Universe
and just sweeping through all things
like a plague I mean it was it was
insane you know the annihilation wave I
mean they just they just went through
world after world after world you know
and it just swept through everything to
the came across and crushing everything
in his path it was literally an army of
bugs that's really what it was the
annihilation wave was just an army of
giant bugs but it was kind of cool to
see because in the end you know it was
just heroes all over the place all over
the universe just totally being crushed
it actually took place during civil war
and it's a great story in and of itself
I've already covered it and I believe
that many over coverage story is going
to be covering that too so it's a really
cool especially when Galactus is finally
freed man he unleashes hell on the
annihilation wave is the coolest thing
he destroys like 2/3 of the forces in a
single blast I guess it's crazy when
he's finally unleashed but the fact
remains here that what Hallows is kind
of running amuck on everything the
guardians are more or less kind of
forced in a situation where they have to
free
they kind of have to make their escape
and leave the planet behind this is kind
of cool because what it shows us is that
the guardians are just as much about
strategy and tactics as they are about
being goofy and silly it's one of those
things where sometimes in order to win
to win a war you have to lose a battle
you have to sacrifice those pawns it's a
classic game of chess you know sacrifice
three pawns put your queen in the right
spot and the game is over you know it's
very much similar to what's happening
right here you know they've got to kind
of sacrifice the planet to a degree
knowing that Gamora is still there
knowing that hala is probably going to
take her frustrations out on the moor
knowing that Peter Quill's been rescued
and how is going to be really engaged
even further they have to make that
sacrifice now in truth they're not going
to give up the life of Gamora I mean
that's not going to happen you know one
of the more jumps back down to the
surface starts facing off against
against against hala
you know the idea here is hey look you
know if we've gotta leave her behind
it's not going to be the biggest deal in
the world she's going to basically live
I mean hollows capable hala can kill
Gamora if she chose to but at the end of
the day she has information that she
wants now with regards to gum or getting
absolutely pummeled by she's getting
wrecked let her eyes all swole up and
everything I mean she's getting just
absolutely destroyed but the guardians
are banking on this because the
guardians are kind of looking around and
saying hey look Collin wants to know
where we're started it's not enough for
her to destroy spar tax she wants Peter
quill to see it because in her mind
Peter quill his father the whole nine
yards the legacy of the ruling class of
spark acts is what led to the
destruction of her home world and so in
her mind she wants
star-lord to see the loss of what he
holds dear and to feel the same pain she
felt it was very visceral for her it's
very real for her it's really kind of a
cool scenario to unfold but the fact
remains you know with Gamora getting
absolutely decimated the Guardians just
kind of show up
now of course Rockets like look guys we
need a plan it's one of the things that
he was kind of talking about so we don't
really know what their plan is for the
moment all that really happens is
star-lord tries to reason with it tries
to say hey look I'm not the one who
destroyed your homeworld my father was
the one who destroyed your homeworld but
of course his father's no longer part of
the equation and so at the end of the
day it doesn't matter you know she
basically said look that may very well
be the case but if the only way for me
to get my revenge is to get revenge on
you despite the fact that your father
was the one who did it then be that as
it may now of course this is when the
plan comes into play and it's actually
really well engineered and it shows us
how well the Guardians work together I
mean he's serving
as a distraction here he's basically
talking to Halle in order to take her
mind away from what's going on around
her and in this moment of distraction
kitty pryde pops out of nowhere uses her
phasing powers and drags Halle halfway
into the ground allowing for Drax to
pummel her you know kind of make her a
little dizzy make her a little bit punch
drawn and in the thing Ben Grimm to jump
from you know a thousand miles in the
air and just land on top of her and so
with Halle more or less being defeated
you know that that's really kind of the
end of that well then suddenly you tad
makes his appearance now again this is
not long this is not drawn out this was
a pretty quick skirmish as him just kind
of being an opportunist kind of trying
to take out the Guardians at the right
time but again there's there's really
not much goin here I mean there's a
little bit of discussion here and there
you know some talking in between the two
of them but for the most part he's
subdued I mean he's kind of beat pretty
easily by drax to destroy her mostly
because of the fact that Drax is the
main guy that he's going after I mean he
actually really kind of a guy that he
has the most beef with and so things
move past pretty quick I mean Drax and
Ben Grimm kind of working together it's
an almost unstoppable force of cheer
physical strength and so with you tat
basically being you know being defeated
and so on and so forth Peter quill goes
back to his normal role but this is when
we find out then again the council was
kind of working against it now in truth
the council was working against Peter
quill because they were being prodded by
the brood Queen and so with her
basically pushing him in the position of
pushing creature up Peter quill to the
point that he would basically just quit
being president well now they're
leaderless I mean they have a council
but at the end of the day the council
can never really vote on any one thing
that will benefit the country or benefit
of the planet consistently that's really
the role of the king you know that's
that's really the role of the Emperor is
to be the guy who basically says here's
what we're going to do we're going to do
it by force the council can vote you
know and they have voted consistently
and they have voted you know with each
other but the question becomes what
happens when a situation unfolds it's
not in all their mutual interest and
that's what the Queen brood is betting
on you know the time that will come when
there will be some kind of decision that
has to be made that will split the
council and that is the point in which
she and Annihilus will step in and
they'll basically conquer Spartak or at
least that's their intention is to
conquer Spartak but again this is just
kind of the all-new all-different
guardians of the galaxy a different take
on the team familiar faces and it still
kind of works but again this is all
really just kind of lead into Peter
quill going back to being the leader of
the team proper but with that being said
guys if you are new here to come as
explain make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the rod core if you
guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
you